foreign
films then um You probably don't need
any additional incentive to not watch
the upcoming sequels from director James
Cameron who hasn't made a decent film in
about I guess it's been probably 20
years
of course the original Avatar back in 29
2009 was a a massive
multi-billion dollar hit but that was
due mostly to this period of mass
societal psychosis that caused millions
of people to believe temporarily that it
was a good film it was very bewildering
time for people like myself who never
fell under this hypnotic trance
um eventually though everyone woke up
from their hallucinogenic stupor and
realized that Avatar was despite the
special effects one of the least
interesting and least inventive films
ever released
it was essentially just Disney's
Pocahontas but with blue people and less
singing it was a film so lacking in wit
and creativity that the natural resource
that everyone is fighting over in the
film now it centers around this natural
resource
and it's called unobtainium because you
know it's difficult to obtain
that that's the level of writing we got
in this film it was the kind of film
where the bad guy is an evil army
officer with a scar on his face who's
motivated to do bad things because you
know he's the evil bad guy and that's
what evil guys do and I would continue
in my critique of the movie but it was
so utterly forgettable that there isn't
much else I could really say about it I
will say that
it was uh one of the only times in my
life that I almost walked out of a movie
in the theater the only reason I didn't
is that I actually fell asleep and it's
it's and this is true it's the only move
I've ever felt I've I've missed like 45
minutes because I took a nice nap thank
God
all of this to say the sequel set to be
released in a couple of weeks is
guaranteed to be terrible now almost all
sequels are terrible even sequels to
good films but sequels to bad films are
doomed from the start because they're
building from a foundation of crap
and yet judging from the director's
recent public statements this sequel
May well be awful in ways that exceed
our wildest expectations so here's the
story from the New York Post it says
James Cameron has revealed that his
long-awaited Avatar sequel is rooted in
his personal issues quote I thought I'm
going to work out a lot of my stuff
artistically that I've gone through as a
parent of five kids Cameron 68 told The
Hollywood Reporter the overarching idea
is that the family is the Fortress it's
our greatest weakness and our greatest
strength I thought I can write the hell
out of this I know what it is to be the
a-hole Dad don't be distracted by
parties and presents this holiday season
instead join Hallows most anticipated
prayer challenge of the Year pray 25 led
by cast members from The Chosen the
largest Christian streaming Series in
history pray 25 will guide you through
meditation and prayer for 25 days
leading up to Christmas pray 25 will
help grow your understanding of mankind
and develop a disciplined prayer habit
during a season when discipline is put
to the test how low is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S and the
number one Catholic app in the world
hallow helps me make prayer a priority
and with pray 25 it can do the same for
you so find peace and and fortify your
faith this Christmas with hallow
download the app for free and join the
pray Tony 5 challenge go to hallow.com
Matt Walsh and get three months
completely free that's hello.com Matt
Walsh to reclaim your piece during this
holiday season
now if somehow a big budget sequel to
the most overrated film of all time made
as a means for the 68 year old director
to work out his personal issues scenes
appealing to you then um wait until you
hear the rest of it
quote reflecting back on his career
which includes highly publicized clashes
with Studio Executives Cameron said a
lot of things I did earlier I wouldn't
do career-wise and just risks that you
take as a wild testosterone poisoned
young man I always think of testosterone
as a toxin that you have to slowly work
out of your system
well good news James it seems that
you've mostly succeeded in that regard
nobody will accuse you of Having excess
testosterone but for the record
um testosterone is not a poison nor is
it a toxin nor is it something that you
want to work out of your system
it is in fact a hormone vital to growth
and vital to development which maintains
among other things your bone density
your muscle mass strength
of course the irony here is that if you
asked him you know about the subject
James Cameron as a Hollywood leftist
would almost certainly tell you that
he's a fan of gender affirmation drugs
and procedures which means that in his
world
testosterone is only a poison when it's
naturally produced
testosterone in the form of a drug given
to gender confused girls is uh is
wonderful
um and it's medically necessary and
affirmative but if it's naturally
produced by men then it's bad
and yet Cameron is really only guilty of
being overly honest here if anything
because this is how our society
generally treats men and boys
young men are poisoned by the toxin of
testosterone we're told that's the
essence of toxic masculinity after all
and you know it's it's true
that young men in particular can be wild
can be aggressive
um can be prone to risk-taking and
confrontation
testosterone indeed plays a big role in
that
but our approach as a culture should be
to help these boys and young men harness
their masculine energy not suppress it
or Purge themselves of it or drug it out
of them
but help them to develop the character
and discipline to funnel all of that
testosterone fueled aggression and
energy in a constructive and worthwhile
Direction
you know this is one of the many things
our society gets wrong when it comes to
men boys as they grow up
um they're not given proper Outlets
and most of the outlets that they once
had are being taken away
even things like the you know more
aggressive and and um sort of violent
games kids used to play on playgrounds
we don't play those games anymore
take all that away
they're not trained on how to harness
this energy they're not trained on how
to be men
they're so often deprived of competent
male role models
we are fearful of masculinity and so we
demand that boys essentially act like
girls and sometimes we literally try to
turn them into girls
and then as they get older and stronger
and become unruly and violent we
conclude that masculinity itself must be
the problem
rather than a lack of guidance a lack of
leadership a lack of moral formation
and the goal becomes as James Cameron
puts it to purge it masculinity to work
it out to eradicate it
and now he's made a movie about it
which you know you can watch if you
don't value your brain or your time or
your money
but I will decline the invitation for my
part and uh instead say to James Cameron
that you sir are
today canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]